نذهب الى الزميل محمد الطيب مراسل جزيره
من حي المعموره جنوبي الخرطوم اهلا بك نقف
معك على المشهد
في الواقع هذا اليوم يوم العيد شهد توسعا
للاشتباكات ما بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع هناك مناطق جديده يعني رصدنا في
هذا اليوم هناك منطقه اشتباكات في شارع
الخرطوم مدني
وبالتحديد قرب المركز الاسلامي سمعنا
اطلاق وتبادل للطلقات ما بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع وتلاحظون خلفي في هذه
المنطقه
تصاعد الدخان من هذه المنطقه يبدو انها
منطقه الصحافه في هذه المنطقه المقابل لها
هيام منطقه الصحافه
هناك اشتباكات قويه وتبادل لاطلاق النار
وهناك انفجارات نسمعها واضحه من هذه
المنطقه
يبدو ان هذه المرحله من العمليات العسكريه
دخلت في مواجهات عنيفه في الواقع كانت قد
بدات قبل فجر اليوم
وقبل صلاه الفجر قبل صلاه العيد ايضا كنا
نسمع اصوات للطائرات
للطيران وكنا نسمع ايضا قذائف هاون تسقط
خلال كل اليوم والليل وحتى في وقت الصلاه
العيد كانت الاشتباكات مستمره لكنها مؤخرا
في قبل
الزوال وقبل منتصف النهار بدات تدخل
معتركا جديدا نسمع ذوية
الرصاص في مناطق مختلفه في الماضي كنا
نسمعه في منطقه قادم من القياده العامه
ومن المطار كانت الاشتراكات تتركز في تلك
المنطقه الان توسعت الى مناطق مختلفه
الجيش السوداني كان قد اعلن انهم
سيمضون في
مرحله جديده اسموها مرحله التمشيط بالنسبه
للاحياء وكذلك الدعم السريع اعلن انه
خلال هذا اليوم على انه يواجه
هجمات جديده من قبل الجيش السوداني في عدد
من المحاور نعم
[موسيقى]
فلذلك لا تزال هذه الهجمات مستمره سمعنا
ايضا عبر مصادر متطابقه تحدث لنا على انه
هناك تبادل لاطلاق النار ما بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في منطقه المربعاته في ام
درمان وما زالت هذه الاشتباكات مستمره
فلذلك هذه الاشتباكات يبدو انها دخلت
مرحله جديده وقد تتصاعد خلال الفتره
المقبله ان لم يكن هناك حل سياسي او ان
الهدنه التي طالبت بها الاحزاب السياسيه
بان يمهل ان تكون هناك مده هدنه لمده
ثلاثه ايام
لتجعل لتهيئ وتصلح الوضع الانساني بالنسبه
للمواطنين وايضا تقوم بعمليات الاخلال لمن
اراد ان يخرج من العاصمه الى الولايات نعم
محمد سمعتك تتحدث عن ان الدخان خلفك يتصعب
منطقه الصحافه وان الاشتباكات كانت ضاريه
هناك هل لنا ان نعرف المزيد عن هذه
المنطقه
وسبب ضراوه هذه الاشتباكات اليوم
اصلها وفصلها وما هي دواعيها